evening all ah game for happened today
girl found playing white and I'm black
why chess explains Oh Chris chess
explains Yeah right okay um so in this
game for we saw d4 again from gelfand
and we saw a repeat of the Slav defense
so after Knight c3 Knight f6 we had um
II free yeah we see a repeater fun game
2 for quite some loose which yeah maybe
a son a bit surprising from what quite a
few at least it's a bit surprising for
me doesn't mean much but I thought that
dumb didn't really look like yeah to
inspiring for white this kind of
position but well let's see what what
happens i think we follow game 2 up to
the tenth move so i think we discussed
this this opening a bit in this video so
i think it doesn't make much sense to to
repeat all this um basically what black
is trying to do is to provoke this b3
move and now the ship to d2 to get this
Bishop displaced on the square so you
know after both castles my critique
retreats sorry 226 with this Bishop yeah
and yeah this is the position where I
golf on plate rook see one in game two I
think right so slight variation and then
yes it's sort of unless white white
could also go here for here but if he
doesn't want to go before then he sort
of needs to play move which is some more
suitable on after black playing he five
because black is pretty much signaling
signaling that yeah that he wants to
play five yeah so quincy two tries to be
a more useful move
then Roxy one yes this pressure on h7
here which might be useful at some point
yeah also the Queen might be well placed
for the C file button actually that's
not significant perhaps but dogs
connected outside oh yeah the rules
connected say hello to each other so
black breaks in the center doesn't again
he doesn't waste a move well waist isn't
pay rocky a he just plays 85 immediately
and white takes on d5 and plays efore
yeah this is quite similar to to to do
to the second game we're also this was
this was plated of course it really
seems that this isolated pawn position
is completely unattractive to girl
frontier I think it's understandable
green on c2 is especially bad in this
kind of structure so i think it was
clear that he wanted to go in for here
well I think it's difficult and this for
me to to understand what's the great
attraction of the setup besides being
that it's a of course a terribly solid
because the center is eliminated now
completely hmm then you get at least
from the bourne structure perspective
complete symmetry yeah in fact so watch
what happens on the day 51 on YouTube
something is phatak happens this game
which I think may be one of the most
interesting points about the game if you
watch the configuration on the deef are
very soon yeah the dealer is very
crowded ready but it gets worse so yeah
and no it took on chuckling deform ok
and now Knight takes d5 because as we've
noted before Knight takes d4 I think we
noted before night c5 but here actually
the Queen's protecting the bishop I
don't know is 95 still the strongest
sort of move in this position or
something stronger yeah yeah what one
thing could be here too
to dell to capture only for twice and
then Knight f6 this could be an issue
already because this would threaten the
show page 200 yes one porn it also sort
of it takes the bishop and you don't
want to yeah yep you don't really want
to move this piece yeah it's it's maybe
not super clear maybe white would have
some compensation after Bishop e3 but
could be it's not completely out of this
world but it's a yeah it looks a bit
fishy but there should be five there
should be five here you should be 50
which we five instruments good you could
also be an idea about what you ran
interview you just walked into self Pena
Bishop e3 54 work 81 ok all right ok but
i think we are you know that before I
think it may be problematic even for for
other reasons so he wants to really open
it up completely with 95 yeah and this
looks um yeah quite quite logical here
black exchanges and now Knight f6 em
gets a special / c eight yeah into play
somewhat yeah and both sides have these
kind of dislocate or loose pawns be able
to collect so they're soon going to
collect each other's loose pawns but
first H free prevents Bishop g4 maybe
and you know I think okay so Bishop d7
no hurry to take on d far we can't
anyway because of the h7 pressure he is
going to actually take even more time to
take on d5 you can take it leisure for a
moment on d5 for a few more moments so
rook ad one that we have this aesthetic
the D files completely crowded here of
the rook 81 so that's one of the most
interesting aspects of the game being
cynical known as good as good game I
don't era if it's certainly not a gamer
which shows them yeah which which is
full of mistakes or something that you
respected
a good game but I think it's a bit
disappointing from White's point of view
what yeah what you got here and think
it's exactly nothing yeah black will get
a tempo here with rook c8 and then Roxy
five as we will see in the game yeah and
well it's just complete complete
symmetry then and you can even argue
that yeah Blake's a bit more active here
and what what white gets is some as you
see here on black plays h6 now I think
yeah it's hard to make love this move
firm if you want to get you five back
and you want to why cannot protect this
I think we should points out I think be
five is that that move be five or is it
something stronger yeah be five is fine
i think after that white would fight for
equality already and now the fibers
capture the fcat Knight c3 may be coming
up yeah like ass got his hooks into play
already okay needs to be cautious about
this d file you know this is always an
issue the rook only one was the Queen 98
but well he decides to go neither five
now grab the bishop pair yeah yeah so
yeah the bishop cannot go back here I
guess well why would be keeping well
this would be dangerous for black
wouldn't it um d6 stuff like d6 ooh yeah
this is one one thing then it's hard to
whether you cannot tolerate this night
on a fine on the main thing so it's
taken off it's funny just a funny
anecdote I I I watched the live on
broadcast from the US Championships I'm
from a few days back end there was a
nice little story that one Grand Master
actually said it's not 95 but knife f5
it's like a knife and the throat this
kind of pizza you don't want to have
this knife
no no f5 especially with h6 is further
weakened you can't evict it or anything
yeah so it's more painful yeah so yard
so yeah so adult sorry we've got so
we've got a slight imbalance but it's
nothing too exciting at the moment the
d5 come is further pressurized now with
rook c5 rather elegantly I suppose to
attendees 5 yeah this is really the main
point if white would have a little bit
of time to get his pieces coordinated
just just one or two moose then maybe
you could try a little bit to to probe
around with this bishop pair but the the
bad thing is that this rook t5 is such
an active piece in the middle of the
board and it's already threatening some
things if you if you look at why play
snooker everyone now yeah this looks BAM
pretty pretty normal and they look 25
and then you've got the first threats
already here coming up black threatening
to to win immediately now with rook
takes you 10 of course yes the pin on
the one yes I'm sorry I we push much too
at the end of it yeah yeah so this is
already a bit a bit shaky so white needs
to place a move 30 maybe yeah he doesn't
really want to play hmm and dumb Jesus
yeah if he plays rook e8 that might be
quite bad as well Queen texier and the
Queen's threatenings come in you know
things like going into Queenie fire fair
also will be double attack on f5 and h 2
ma jus look Ricky one might Perry this
here um possibly ah actually Ricky 5
here and it's uncomfortable still not
not not totally sure okay but yeah rook
takes EA doesn't not cry um yeah I'm
unlucky eight maybe just also and what
about 98 oh by the way Knight takes ah
yes sir also sort of threatening Bishop
h2o wish me to yes
it's not just win material but it sort
of friends to get rid of the bishop pair
white cannot move the bishop because of
yeah check on h2 maybe this is also a
bit bit uncomfortable yeah I just bet
green e8 also look fine it doesn't yeah
that doesn't scare me you if I want to
need to take with the Queen you're so so
nicely centralized so and it's also the
bishop pair really am it really helps on
the bishop pair outside if the points
are are not symmetrical like if we in
for instance if you would have a
situation where let's say black H porn
would be missing I'm at this is a bad
example what is just say um a black
would have is this piece be seven point
on e6 yeah like four against three on
the kingside at two against one on the
queenside then the bishop pair would
really work I'm trying to push the pawns
but here there's nothing much to check
only if you get rid of all the major the
heavy pieces here then at the end you
can think of something like bishop CA
but black has so much time to to get a
proper setup it's um it's just nothing I
guess that he needs to play as this
bishops III now yeah then black even
exchanges more yes unfortunately it's
not a crown pleased with I think the
symmetrical porn structures are aren't
usually that crowd pleasing and here um
yeah there's the simplification Morse
impression way but if anything black has
a you know very nice control in the
position doesn't he on the default and
yeah what yeah okay what now needs to
it's not like super difficult but if you
would play some nothing moves here let's
say a 4 or something and black would
really get this kind of position with
them with the night against the bishop
then yeah he can sometimes it can
even fine for black if you control the
default and have some ideas to maybe
play rock d 224 imagine a position where
the the bishops I exchanged a bishop
before now and what what girlfriend did
was immediately getting rid of the Queen
and this is I think a very good idea
because the screen night combination
potentially could could be an issue so
this Quincy to i think is a good move
for a necessary one may be right it's
not like the other things are losing but
i think it's just a helpful for white to
to play this Quincy eight what were you
see in the game you should be for now
all right yes forcibly get rid of the
Queen's bit naughty for the the crowd
unfortunately when the Queen's come off
some people fall asleep in the game so
Queen same force began but it's the safe
thing to do here and the bishop we kind
of skewing the pawns if it was taken
yeah so g6 in fact was played and the
bishop just retreated hair so Juliet
exercise précisément ought to get get
this Bishop of this c8 diagonal to see
edge is little trap use that night takes
G full rook e8 check well ya know this
is in fact fire now there's no the
Ribeiro mate if you end it now this
check its check it wins the Queen yeah
stuff you can easily overlook it it's
game automatically as you lady would
would need to take back here okay but h5
is I think very precise and then yeah
white needs to take here doesn't have a
bishop move anymore okay so Bishop are
free okay attacking a pawn that the
pawns are now moved one of them onto the
Dalton square away from the bishop good
safety policy to get the pawns off
sometimes off off the color of the
bishop yeah this is now nicely done b6
and a five for up to six and then
everything's protected nicely and yeah
time to shake hands really yes just just
nothing
unfortunately it's not like one of those
worlds tell games or sparf games to the
info which I would doing later I've got
some wins to do from another Olympiad
but but it's just they're very very
strong players I mean I mean girlfriends
been upto 2760 I'll looking is you know
he's been up there on the feed a rating
as well towards 2800 you know he's like
world class and ranked 20 in the world
so it's good you know it's a tight match
at the moment um but ok so night d 5
might be threatening night f4 and that's
so what does play g3 cautiously yeah and
okay the Knights has the night got any
useful purpose otherwise he went night e
seven I'm what you think of other
alternatives they don't really um I
guess they don't really do anything
night before you know you just wants to
yeah it doesn't it doesn't really add do
much now then the night doesn't have a
good squared she let me travel three and
get ready to return to be big trouble
actually after route you end up losing
haha in this frame again I get to serve
into trouble yeah you just wanted to
have a position I'd only seven queen a
king to have six to e6 and then like
place king f 66 until hell freezes over
yes for King 27 yeah what cannot do
anything so it's just it's just nothing
so here they shook hands let's imagine
so so you're safe on a position which
they shook hands draw move for ya but
rook c7 so we're saying King f6 is that
the right yeah I think maybe just King
f6 to e6 and then you just do nothing
fortress I've white cannot make any any
progress here you know the rook ambition
are not going to coordinate on any pawns
once they're on dark squares these pawns
are safe enough yeah the night it's got
nice access against f5 like in a
previous game yeah so this this is a
solid game okay
a-arm we do a quick a brief summary then
another Slav following same moves as an
earlier game with this disruptive Bishop
b4 which is actually seen in quite a few
opening variations to get this bishop in
an awkward place yeah this is seen in
the Queen's Indian the Catalan and in a
way inside a bogo Indian and in quite a
lot of Queens pawn openings to to
dislocate this Bishop so this position
would be much better in comparison of
white would ever wish upon be to you
know but I'm a bit really it's not like
I think I'm being pretty realistic about
this kind of games you can cannot expect
those trial works kind of games all the
time yeah but it is a bit disappointing
from White's point of view that you
really didn't get near slightest kind of
pressure it's difficult of course
nowadays to to really get something with
white but it's it's an opening that that
was repeated here so you could expect
this and its really a bit lame because
white why does have other other options
like on one move for plane idea 3some
something sharp oh yeah yeah um well
this is if you feel if you consider you
would prepare this with the with the
computer you you can easily imagine this
kind of move some being played out it's
it's very logical 9 f6b should be seven
rupee a droop syedna so kind of moves
you would probably play in a blitz game
also so the first stuff you look at and
I don't know I think it looks like like
pretty much nothing and it's not like
it's difficult for Felicia to to find
those kind of moves and it I think you
didn't really set so so many problems
now yeah so the question you know it's
always difficult for me to to to to
criticize those kind of players because
they're immensely strong but I think
yeah he needs to win a game at some
point unless you you think you would
have equal chance in the tiebreak which
I don't hmm you know if that's what I
wishes strategy is just to get to the
tiebreak to the is a 30-minute chess
move increment yeah I'm not sure maybe
25 minutes or something but well it's
not a strategy for him 2 2 to get into
the tiebreak from for sure but well he's
got black what what can he do his places
it's a classical player and it's not not
like he's playing and I know the bangko
gambit suddenly or some other but not
too solid opening it's just business but
actually in in the match against kramnik
it was quite dynamic wasn't his King was
in the center there were double palms
and games sure it was very very exciting
no Slavs so this yeah kind of the dollar
side of the Slav being visited in this
match yeah but yeah the thing is it's
just what also what what white is wise
doing and you cannot what wrong also a
lot of this sharp stuff to happen which
known which girl phone doesn't really
play into here it takes two to tango
this is the same hidden fee and it's not
a matter of one player play sure it is
it's really not not necessary for for
for someone to to really sharpen it up
with black gum yeah like um yeah like
force a sharpening of the position is
it's just he likes more thing to to care
to counter-attack if the other side is
trying something but yeah this is really
a bit I shall just know it's something I
don't know if we should mention this you
should takes f6 hair black would play
more black plain hair in this position
officially are six white she takes f6 is
some no problem g takes have six yeah i
don't think it's a problem really right
because Queen takes f6 there might be a
nasty thing going on here yeah it's good
yeah it's good to mention Chevy so no
selfmade here ouch oh haha that will be
painful so G takes f6 was actually
assumes then this position yeah I was
only thinking of there there's some
check tix or something but I don't think
there are no yeah but you can you can do
that it's know a little bit deal yeah
it's no big deal her because the default
bishop coordinating on f2 that that's
not good is it ya black ass some counter
check that the bishop is somewhat stupid
on there five in the structure it would
be safely positioned on c4 some
something then maybe there would be
something but this way yeah it's just um
just pretty pretty sort of too much
pieces exchanged interesting forcing
more possible to see that yeah so okay
so bishops so Bishop c5 now again not
minding bishop f6 here and that was
rejected just for the Queen c2 um okay
so Bishop default and then we got the
exchange and then and then it's settled
down tactically there we get we get a
black constructing the fortress
impenetrable fortress the King making
its way if needed to protect the night
yeah but just what one thing got a match
strategy girlfriend always stresses that
he plays game after game and he doesn't
really believe in something like a match
strategy i'm not sure i think they are
there are some some aspects maybe but um
one one thing which is certainly true um
i think the the if you've got two
players and one player is considered a
little bit of an outsider in the match
which is a favor yeah so i think it's
it's always it's the shorter the short
of the distance gets in terms of the
amount of games the more closer this
kind of match would get so maybe
girlfriend is just saying okay I'm
playing solidly let's see what happens
and if it gets close to to the end like
game 10 or something you can always step
up the risk and if you win then then
there's really really little room to to
come back young so you know think that's
that be mounting the strikes though for
just one yeah the stakes like huge
online then yeah this kind of decisive
game situations or something else so
maybe this is the kind of idea to well
you cannot sometimes well chess is not
like witchcraft we awaken out of nowhere
cool some technical fireworks nobody
could even play as my childhood if if
you look at saw gains will this really
solid players you don't see any
fireworks because they simply pull the
plug so early Victor I cannot sacrifice
anything where there are games like this
and nowadays one would defend some very
much improved at some sometimes
difficult but you need to take a little
bit of risk and this was kind of the the
no risk approach so it yeah this was the
I think the bleakest game so far what
what can you do but then let's hope for
fun and with white may be here trying to
check out the groom father again or
which sets you some mother opening no
yep ok um alright ok thanks sir chris um
yeah sure ok um I hope for everyone on
YouTube got something out of this um ok
ok thanks very much it'll be on both for
channels see you in the next game thanks
for my solo I thirst there ok see you
later Cheers kiss